[Applause]
[Music]
hello well very good morning to you all
and especially to representative Adam
Smith from the 9th congressional
district of the state of Washington and
let me declare from the outset
congressman that any that the
combination of your first and last names
makes you particularly special yesterday
I yes we Republicans always profoundly
disappointed to discover that I'm a
Democrat so um welcome again and please
tell us what why you here ah you invited
me actually invited myself well I'd like
to talk a little bit this morning about
our policy towards Russia and how things
have shifted and actually a couple years
ago I was in a conversation with general
Dunford before he was chairman the Joint
Chiefs staff talking about the threats
that we faced and I have long felt that
the greatest threat that the United
States faces is from violent extremism
or radical Islamist terrorist groups
like Isis and al Qaeda in the
ideological struggle there and he
disagreed with me and said that he felt
Russia was the most profound threat that
we faced middle argument back and forth
about that and I could possibly think
and he was correct because my basic
thinking was whatever Russia may do may
be doing groups like Isis and Al Qaeda
and others are the only ones that get up
every morning hoping to kill as many
Americans as is humanly possible and the
only thing stopping them is the ability
to do so and that and don't get me wrong
that is still a pretty profound threat
but Russia has actually built a very
large organization that is fundamentally
aimed at undermining democracy for lack
of a better way to put it and they sort
of evolved into this position but they
restarted the great power competition
between Russia and the United States and
we didn't notice for a while they have
been trying to undermine elections they
have been spreading messages they have
really sort of introduced the modern way
to way
information campaign taking advantage of
the internet taking advantage of social
media to spread their message in a
variety of different ways and put very
simply what Putin is trying to do is
he's trying to make the world safe for
autocratic dictatorship as an
interesting story of sort of how he came
to this belief but it is his fundamental
belief that the people cannot govern
themselves he fears mobs and riots and
chaos more than anything she'd do
something wrong no no no I'm all
standing at the tension report required
to stand so and part of that is to
maintain control in Russia because he
does not want the Russian people to
think that democracy is for them or that
they should have a free voice in their
government that they should have freedom
of press or anything like that because
he wants to maintain control and power
but he's since sorted to spread that
more broadly and his efforts to
undermine the NATO alliance his efforts
to undermine the EU and basically he's
not so much trying to take over these
places at this point as he is trying to
simply make them faith even with the
Ukraine to a certain degree it's more a
matter of making sure that the Ukraine
doesn't fall into Western hands and is
seen as a failure then it is a matter of
taking over the Ukraine and yes they
have been hacking into and using cyber
warfare to try to influence elections
not just ours but elections across
Eastern Western Europe and elsewhere in
a way to do that he basically wants to
make the case that liberal democracy
doesn't work now in Syria is another
example of this Assad as an ally and
certainly gives Russia a port and its
support in a variety of ways but he's
also an autocratic dictator and the
Putin is going to want to support him to
show that that's the best way to run it
and Libya Russia is now and I always get
the guys name but they're backing a
similar autocratic dictator to sort of
be the strong man to take over Libya and
like I said part of this is a very
heartfelt belief that this is the proper
way to run a government
and that it's the only way that we can
govern and have any sort of peace and
stability in the world now the reason
this becomes more problematic is because
Russia as many you probably know is
actually in a great deal of trouble
economically speaking they have a
shrinking population and an aging
population they don't have a very strong
economy they're dependent upon the price
of oil and Putin is not going to be able
to fix that now what he has unified the
people around is the notion that Russia
should be a great power
so he's unified them around the idea
that Russia has been treated poorly
there was the whole experience under
Boris Yeltsin where people sort of felt
like there were a joke and the economy
collapsed so he has upheld his his power
he's actually rather popular in Russia
because he's asserting himself again
they're not being pushed around by the
United States or the West and the threat
that I see is how long is that going to
last how long before the economy becomes
so bad that President Putin feels like
he needs to do something else to
reinstall those feelings of nationalism
and more than anything we need a
comprehensive strategy to attempt to
counter this because they have a message
and they're trying to deliver it they
are trying to undermine our allies
undermine democracy you've heard I'm
sure about what's been going on with
Qatar and the other Arab nations and the
conflict there this is a ledge but a big
chunk of what got that started was a
speech that was presented I believe it
was the Qatari foreign minister I forget
which person in which he spoke about the
need to get closer to Iran and it was a
very detailed speech about that only
trouble is he never gave it didn't exist
didn't happen it simply showed up on the
internet one day and was spread around
and everyone believed it and it has been
traced back to some of the same Russian
hackers that have engaged in other
things
this was Russia's way which isn't to say
that there wasn't conflict between Qatar
and Saudi Arabia and Egypt already but
this was just throwing gasoline on the
fire to further destabilize the Middle
East and East a
lies the people who Saudi Arabia and
others who were trying to go against
Assad and against Iran which are
Russians partners so they're very clever
about how they're doing all of this and
we're not we are not really engaged in
this struggle in any sort of way
we don't have a clear message and was
certainly not using the cyber tools and
the information warfare that Russia is
using to present that message now why
does any of this matter well first of
all I believe it matters whether or not
liberal democracy continues to move
forward I think it is the best form of
government and is also the form of
government that leads to a more peaceful
result if people have a voice in their
government and feel like they have a
voice in their government perhaps more
importantly and are invested in it you
tend to have a more peaceful world this
was the post-world War two order that we
set up after two world wars had
virtually destroyed the planet and we'd
seen the result of nationalism and
fascism and all of that we wanted to
offer a better model a model based on
alliances and partnership and yes
capitalism and also freedom and
democracy and granted you can pick apart
a number of different things that happen
over the course of the last 70 years and
say it wasn't perfect but we avoided
world wars and I think we move forward
economically poverty has been reduced
significantly in the world just for one
example based on that model and that
model is now crumbling and Russia is the
primary force trying to crumble it so
I'm introducing a bill today to call for
a comprehensive strategy to counter
Russian aggression and a key part of
that is alliances is keeping those who
are in favor of capitalism and liberal
democracy and freedom and openness and
by the way kleptocracy is another big
part of how Russia governs
the elites steal all the money from
everybody else which is another reason
why this form of government is
problematic
so take the opposite approach of
transparency and openness and economic
freedom and political freedom and try to
promote that
and we need certainly to counter what
Russia has been doing on the Internet in
their information campaign and the cyber
warfare that they have done we also need
to restring Fionn our alliances because
what Russia does in Eastern Europe is
going to depend a great deal on how much
they think they can get away with on
whether or not they feel like there is
an adequate deterrence and if NATO
phrase if the EU phrase if we appear
divided and against one another it's
going to embolden Russia so we need to
re-establish ourselves in Eastern Europe
with our allies to push back against all
of this but to begin with we simply need
a strategy an approach and recognize the
threat that Russia presents to our
interests I believe if they are allowed
to continue destabilizing countries to
stabilizing democracies pushing towards
greater autocracies kleptocracy 'z that
it will lead to a more unstable world
and more conflict and I actually watched
a unfortunately was I pulled a muscle in
my back a couple weeks ago and wasn't
able to do much in the History Channel
was doing a special on the rise of
Nazism and a big part of it was they
were so economically down they needed
something to make themselves feel better
and they sort of slowly moved forward
with that and making themselves feel
better it wasn't enough eventually they
had to then conquer territory and had to
really build up the nationalistic
feeling instead of simply doing the
basics of governance and the basics of
governments are building a stronger
economy building greater transparency
building stronger government
institutions so that you have a better
better place to live so that's why I'm
here is to discuss this and how we might
put ourselves in a better position to
counter that Russian influence and more
than anything to try to let people know
that it is a threat it is a threat to
our way of life and to our ability to
prosper and most importantly to a
peaceful world
thanks for this tour of the horizon
congressman there is a photo from one of
those innumerable Syria support working
groups that secretary Kerry used to
convene I'd say almost weekly and where
he invited Sergey Lavrov the Foreign
Minister of Russia to be his co-chair
and the photo shows secretary Kerry
addressing the group of foreign
ministers from the podium and Sergey
Lavrov checking messages on his phone
how did it come to this how did it come
to to the Russian Foreign Minister
ignoring the US Secretary of State you
were a great early supporter of the
reset with Russia where did we go wrong
well and I I'm gonna say a lot of things
here I don't pretend to be an expert
about this I will say this and if there
are experts in the room I want to fill
in some of the details and contradict it
basically with the collapse of the
Soviet Union that was a real opportunity
and the opportunity was to move us out
of our bipolar world and to move Russia
into the multipolar world because
ultimately what can help make a more
stable globe it's not good for America
to be the sole remaining superpower I
know that's sort of controversial we
want to dominate we want to it's just
not good because the rest of the world
resents it first of all second of all
the rest of the world is not
sufficiently invested in peace and
stability so broadly speaking the model
for how we get to a more peaceful and
prosperous world is to get more powers
involved and invested in global
stability and you can look around the
world and very easily see who those
powers should be us obviously the
European Union Russia is a very powerful
country they should be part of this
China should be part of this Brazil
should be part of this they're having
their struggles these days India
Australia there are a lot of countries
and we all ought to work together and
then what are the threats that face our
globe both terrorism and instability if
you are a country that is
ended upon a economic trade and
interaction and stability you want to
try to combat that we can work together
to do that
climate change energy crisis all of
these issues disease we can work
together as great powers in a multipolar
world to do that and that was the goal
after the Soviet Union collapsed is to
reintegrate Russia into that now where
did that go wrong first of all it went
wrong because we took a little bit too
big of a victory dance which I think
Russia resented they have their pride
after all having been a power for
centuries and the expansion of NATO
whatever we may have said about it and
whatever the truth may have been they
saw it as a threat they saw it as the
United States creeping towards their
border and they resented it and it
started to raise alarm bells within
Russia the second thing that happened
and this is something that I don't know
exactly how to overcome I was in Russia
in 1998 and the basic things that we
take for granted in our society Russia
has never been governed properly and by
never I mean never I mean in like
hundreds of years they went from czars
to communists and added little things
stand out in you but I remember talking
to over there and I'm not sure if this
is still true or not but at the time
they didn't have mortgages if you wanted
to buy a home or buy a business you
couldn't borrow money to do it just the
basic funding going forward which
obviously gave rise to a lot of the the
criminal oligarchs that took advantage
of this as well Ike Skelton said at the
time he loved the Kotel that we went
there he's what Russia needs is they
need more citizens they need more people
that understand what it means to be a
citizen in a representative democracy to
participate in but they didn't know I
mean where would they have learned this
how would they have learned how to
govern themselves how to have elections
how to do things they hadn't done it and
so as the late 90s hit in addition to
the creeping of NATO and the feeling
that Russia was being pushed into a
second-tier status their economy
completely and utterly collapse
Boris Yeltsin did not exactly put a
positive image on the global stage he
was a pure denier 18 different points to
be something of a clown and Russia
became a laughingstock and they didn't
much like this so we lost that
opportunity and then came Putin and
Putin's outlook is formed in large part
as I understand it by the fact that he
happened to be in East Berlin when the
wall came down he was the KGB officer
and charged there and a mob showed up
outside of his where where there because
they knew where the KGB station was and
he had to like bluff his way out of not
getting all his people killed and that
chaos terrified him so he became
convinced that a strong armed strong
Iron Fist if you will is the only way to
govern the rabble and then when he was
put into power there was still an
opportunity when George W Bush stared
into his eyes and saw his soul if we all
remember that there was still an
opportunity here I think I'm not sure he
can't know for sure what was in Putin's
mind but NATO continued to expand Russia
continued to feel threatened their
economy wasn't doing particularly well
and so Putin decided that the way to
unify his country was to get back to a
us against them mentality and to say
that what's good for the West is bad for
Russia and to reassert itself and they
do this even militarily as I'm sure
you've heard they're increasingly
buzzing our coasts and buzzing our
planes and going by our ships just to
show that I mean with what's that going
to accomplish they're not going to do
anything it's just to show that they can
to show that they are a power that is
not to be messed with
so that was the lost opportunity I think
to do a reset and it's not the
opportunity isn't completely gone what
worries me like I said is that in order
for Russia to succeed in an order for
Russia to change this viewpoint two
things have to happen one thing is Putin
has to go out of power because he's not
changing his mind on any of that stuff
that I said and a lot more that I have
and to is Russia needs to begin to
succeed they need to begin to have
broad-based economic opportunity so that
they can see a greater benefit in being
part of the global order now the front
page in New York Times this morning had
people protesting in Russia against the
lack of political freedom and the
Russian police beating them so the
Russian people definitely feel like they
are being put down that's the ultimate
failure of what Putin is doing it's a
small amount of money or sorry it's a
lot large amount of money for everyone
at the top and the folks down below
there are really really struggling so
you would look at that and say well
improve the economic system but Putin
may look at and say let's invade Estonia
let's build in what what Hitler did
brilliantly the people who felt who
brought Hitler to power didn't want to
go to war they don't want in you do with
war Hitler sold himself as a person of
peace but look you know Germans in the
Sudetenland of Czechoslovakia are being
persecuted and tortured and killed we
must stand up and defend them and he
sort of slowly spread that message and
it's got an eerie similarity to Putin
saying that ethnic Russians in Ukraine
in Estonia and all the other places
where there are large populations of
ethnic Russians are being discriminated
against and punished and we must end up
and fight for them and where does it
stop if he starts doing that you
mentioned Syria let me go back to Syria
because it worries me a great deal and
I'll explain why towards the end of
towards the very end of the Obama
administration late last year Defence
Secretary Ashton Carter said that in
Syria Russia was doing exactly the
opposite of what it said it would do
instead of attacking Isis it was
attacking nobody pro-western leave that
by the way pro-western yeah well exactly
my next point was that the only surprise
in that for most of us was that the
administration admitted it that late but
the fact
remains that we are at odds
perhaps diametrically opposed in Syria
and just the other Saturday last
Saturday in a phone call that according
to the Russian sources was initiated by
secretary Tillerson Sergei Lavrov told
him in no uncertain terms that it's
unacceptable for Russia that the u.s.
bombs pro-assad militia as they did we
struck Prasad militia now what happens
if as I think he is very likely to do us
deploys chemical weapons again and and
the Russia already you know the Russians
told Tillerson when he was in Moscow
that that any retaliation against that
is unacceptable to Russia I published a
piece last short piece last last year
after our cruise missile attack on Assad
following the chemical weapons attack by
him it was titled so what's the plan mr.
president so what do you think the plan
should be in Syria I mean we are in a
very risky untenable situation there yes
we are and I think the Obama
administration was very naive about that
the Trump administration not so much if
they're naive or if there's a whole hell
of a lot of things going on there that
are very very troubling which we can get
into in a minute but why actually was
that a briefing that national security
adviser McMaster was conducting and they
were still talking about working with
Russia to get to an agreement to have a
replacement for Assad and I said they
interrupted and said you understand that
that's simply not going to happen
Russia wants Assad in power period end
of story and they are never going to
agree to anything else and so we should
stop wasting our time negotiating with
the Russians over any of this even the
notion of negotiating so-called safe
zones then the negotiate them and then
Russia will bomb
they're too mean they want Assad in
power and I don't care about anything
else so I think first of all we have to
be very very clear-eyed about that and
understand that dealing with Russia on
it isn't going to get us anywhere now
what can we do about it there really
isn't a lot we can do about it I think
what you're going to have to have in
Syria and I read something a while ago
is something not as good but along the
lines of the Dayton Accord we simply
divide up the country where Assad is
going to have his little peace and
hopefully the Kurds and some others are
going to have their little peace and
that's going to be it because we're not
going to get rid of Assad and we can
stop him from taking over the entire
country but we are not unless we're
willing to go into a full-scale war
which isn't in our best interests so I
think a stalemate in Syria is the best
that we can hope for and I think we need
to stop being naive that we can somehow
negotiate with the Russians over this
well you touched upon it in your
introductory statement I would like to
go there again I believe it was at the
Council on Foreign Relations where you
said I quote Putin has made his decision
make no mistake about it
he wants the West to be weakened because
he views it in sort of Cold War
mentality as a zero-sum game as you said
what's bad for the West is good for
Russia I hope and I quote you that we
can find a way to convince him that this
is not the case but it's a significant
challenge I think this is this is
exactly right
I think but but what's at the bottom of
this attitude and you actually touched
on this and I would like to for you to
expand on this I think part of the
problem we have with Russia and
certainly China is that America and
Americans live largely in the present
where's where's the Russians and the
Chinese in addition to living in the
present 11 the 11 cents or US are also
operating in a very complex often
painful
our wide historical play historical
context and in Russia there's a very
good book by Howard French their recent
book on the Chinese regime and what he
says there I think is almost hundred
percent applicable to Russia that is
that the regime envelops itself and
pushes on the people the narrative of
resentment and recovery resentment and
restoration and much of that narrative
is is based on falsifications it based
sometimes on outright mythology make low
make it making it to look dubious to us
even ridiculous but apparently it's
quite meaningful to the large segments
of the Russian in Chinese populations
and and that is the political
constituency of Putin's regime and to
him the opinion of that constituency and
catering to it is much more important
than the opinion of Western democracies
there's two very important things that
you said I'm sorry no more attention no
no that's fine two very important things
you said there and the one is oh I could
go off at all very very far down a
rabbit hole I'm explaining this so I
will try not to but I've recently had an
epiphany here that there is no truth
anymore and that what the Internet has
done and what the ability to alter
images I was adobe has a presence in my
district and they do the Photoshop and
all that there is no reality anymore
it's or that's overstatement it can very
easily be shaped and I've been I've
always said my very first campaign when
I ran for the state Senate which is a
very long story but I was 23 years old
nobody had thought I had a snowball's
chance in hell so I had to basically do
it myself just thinking about it it was
a much calmer more peaceful time and
which not everyone was paying attention
to every election in the world so it was
easy to do but I came up with a very
simple sentence in terms of what you're
doing in any situation and that is you
are developing a message and trying to
deliver
to the people who are most likely to
vote in the election you're trying to
persuade an audience and that applies to
a campaign but it also applies just
about everything else that you're trying
to do in life you are trying what's your
message and how do you deliver it but
the truly fascinating part of it to me
is once you've decided who your audience
is where do they get their information
that's the part that they word now and
back in 1990 and if I might just get
wistful for a moment such a simple
simple time basically there were 15,000
households that contain the people that
were going to decide my fate and I knew
what my message was and I knew where
they lived so I knocked on their doors
relentlessly and sent the mail end of
story
now with the internet with the ability
of messages to spread like this it's a
lot more complicated and also it happens
so fast and in so many different ways
that there's no way for anyone really to
check but the truth is I mentioned the
guitar story that is what Russia is
doing in how they are spreading their
message there was a great article just
that I got it in my clips I don't know
when it came out and the political about
how Russia is using Twitter and other
things to target people who serve in the
US military and to target their families
and to send them messages and to get
them to resend them and once you say you
don't no longer do you have to care
about what the actual truth is you just
figure out what's going to be a good
message that's going to drive home my
point and then people will retweet it
they'll post it on Facebook they'll send
it to other people and you spread that
message out there now the same thing can
be done with truthful messages as well
and honestly I think they can be as
effective but we're not even doing that
in that comprehensive way so number one
is you got to get that we've got to
start countering the message that Russia
is sending out there which is basically
that the West is a joke that sorry but
things like yesterday's cabinet meeting
do not exactly help and delivering that
message but we have to try and get the
message out there that capitalist
democracy is war
kid and frankly we have to be less
concerned about fudging the facts a
little bit I've had to get better at
this as people where I was I was round
up I'm a politician you know it's like I
was running against a 16 year incumbent
so I said she's been in office for
nearly 20 years you know and actually a
personal favorite stat was they came out
with a ranking of the members of the
Washington State Legislature that year
the newspapers used to do that there
were a hundred and forty-seven members
of the legislature if I'm doing my math
correctly and my opponent was ranked I'm
challenging myself with math here but
she was ranked just on the other side of
the top half so I generated in the
bottom half of all the legislature
serving by one but it's still true so
you got to be cover about how you send
out that message and do that and that
this point could go on and on and on in
terms of how we counter it the second
thing that you said which is really
important is how do we get Russia to
change because negotiating with them and
hoping right now that they're just going
to see things differently is a complete
and utter waste of time we have to
challenge them number one most important
thing I think is we have to show enough
strength to deter them from further
aggression Assad is baked into the cake
at the moment and going to war to try to
take him out not going to happen Libya a
little bit of a different story we can
comprehensively get in there and make
sure he doesn't get another strongman
propped up in Libya that will serve his
interests we can reinforce the Baltic
States we can forward deploy troops we
can start giving Ukraine more offensive
weapons so that the cost of what Putin
is doing goes up I think it is
incredibly important out where does that
lead it's a long game it's going to take
a while but you know not to keep coming
back to Hitler but if the whole world
had stood up and said sorry you're not
going into the suit at lon we would have
had a conflict earlier but 66 million
people wouldn't have died so I think we
have to really stand strong that's why
reaffirming article
five of NATO is so important we have to
show him that there is going to be a
high cost for this adventurism that it
is not going to prop up Russia that's
step one this was this was you know your
your your taking things right out of my
nose but I still have to ask you a
question
on this yes you're absolutely right and
and you spoke about that at the Council
on Foreign Relations one thing you said
there is that there is a need to get
them to take a step back if I could
explore this a little bit today foreign
policy successes are by far the most
powerful legitimizing factor in Putin's
regime yeah
of course the downside of that is that
he can make them up as well yes well
that'd be that'd be that as it may
yes now the if I understood you
correctly and I certainly concur with
that if that's the correct understanding
the only way for us to change Putin's
mind and this is this is the title of
the of the piece I published last year
as well is to increase the domestic
political costs of his foreign policy
adventures at the moment the brilliant
or seemingly brilliant sequence of
successes is what compensates for very
dire straits of Russian economy and the
idea I think the strategic plan ought to
be to make Putin shift the basis of his
legitimacy where it was before largely
2012 that is continuing economic
progress which he cannot deliver unless
he engages in very serious structural
domestic political reforms to address
the toxic domestic investment climate
which is at the bottom of Russia's
economic straits today how do we do that
I think let let me quote again I believe
you you said to CNN that you and
Chairman Matt Thornbury of the House
Armed Services Committee and others
including Senator McCain have called for
more aggressively helping the Ukrainians
against the Russian and true
giving them more weapons more support
more help in a variety of different ways
than the Obama administration has called
for the goal I think ought to be to make
in the eyes of Putin's key
constituencies which all that matters to
him domestically because he's trying to
save the regime and that's a political
imperative to make foreign policy are
not a source of national pride not a
sequence of brilliant glamorous
successes but something like what
happened in Afghanistan with the Soviet
Union source of embarrassment remorse
and perhaps resentment is that this
strategy well this is - yes but this is
just now occurring to me but going back
to my basic premise of develop a message
and deliver it we not only have to do
that but in this bizarre world that
we're living in I think it's even more
important that we find ways to get
messages to the Russian people about the
failures of Putin now this isn't going
to happen overnight because Putin has
you know managed to gain a monopoly on
the media and again there are certain
domestic us analogies here that are
troubling that we can get into but he
has managed to spread his message so
let's say that we were successful in
rolling him back into Ukraine we not
only have to be successful we have to
make sure that the bulk of the Russian
people are aware of it so I think it's
even more important that we develop a
cyber messaging effort you know Voice of
America back in the day where we have
got to do what Putin is doing globally
you know this again it's it's all about
a campaign it would all I never wanted
my opponent to occupy a space it would
drive me crazy if like there was a
message out there in a given area and I
had nothing on to counter it all right
well depending I mean if he was
occupying a space that no one was paying
attention to that I was perfect
okay with that but if it's a space that
matters to have your opponent dominate
it is death and right now this messaging
on the Internet Putin is occupying that
space so in addition to what you said I
think we have to get incredibly
aggressive about planting new stories
about getting the message into the
Russian people and I'm not saying it's
easy and this is like way beyond my area
of expertise in terms of how you would
go about doing this but we have to start
doing that and and of course we have to
do what's the message to begin with the
message is that Putin's a failure that
he's failing the Russian people and the
good news is he is okay when you look at
the economy of Russia when you look at
the utter lack of the middle class when
you look at the kleptocracy the way they
run the thing the lack of opportunity of
your average Russian person the facts
are on our side but we've got to get
that message out and then we also have
to find ways to get a message out about
how what he's doing in foreign policy is
not working and there's a whole bunch of
different ways to do that but we don't
have anybody even working on it right
now
well Kuhn I should meet separately
because as a member of the governor of
broadcasting Board of Governors we do do
things and yeah we enough money to do it
ah now you're talking and we apparently
want to give you less yes and look I you
know aircraft carriers are beautiful
things but these days information is
what it's all about yeah yep honey to my
ears but let me let let us now let us
know touch touch on the elephant that's
been in the room and just before we go
to questions I wanted to - you come and
that is the Russian American hacking the
Russian operation the DNC and so on
you told a s CNN interviewer I quote the
most important point is that is what
Russia is doing not just the DNC but all
around the world undermining the
Alliance's that we have that kept peace
and stability in the world different
groups that we have formed the alliances
we have Russia once all that krump
I think I think this is exactly right
because you're putting the the American
hacking DNC and so on and so forth in a
much wider context I mean look the
Russians started hacking Estonia ten
years ago then then they're followed
Ukraine in there followed Turkey
numerable countries and institutions
until it finally surfaced in the u.s.
yes it's an important segment of their
operation but just only one and then you
continued by saying I hope we could get
past the partisanship I for one am over
the election Donald Trump one he's the
president okay I hope he does the job I
hope he stops worrying about how that
makes his election look and starts
worrying about the Russian what the
Russians are doing going to do to take
away the very freedoms that so many
Republicans claim to hold dear I think
this is a very good place for us to have
your concluding comments before we go to
question and answers
sure how to put this exactly well the
concern that I have is that our
president is operating off of a
different agenda than even his own
cabinet and I don't know what that
agenda is I could speculate and I
probably will in a few seconds but so
you've got the Secretary of State saying
all right Qatar is unbelievably
important to the United States we've got
the central command there whatever
differences may exist between them and
Saudi Arabia in these other places we
need to resolve this as quickly as
possible the Secretary of State who
works for the president last time I
looked at the flow chart an hour later
president Trump is like and I understand
the Democrats are not supposed to use
the f-word anymore so I won't to hell
with that
guitars bad actor and we got to take him
down
okay um since the president this is
Secretary of State and they seem to be
in different places president Trump's
entire national security team agreed
then the speech he gave I believe it was
in Brussels that he needed to reaffirm
Article five as I understand it it was
in and again I hate the fact that they
don't let me swear anymore it was in the
speech and he simply chose not to say it
everybody in know his White House want
him do it he chose not to say it they
had to roll pence out the next day to
say it now I know much of other people
who have led a letter to the president
saying look I know it seems sort of
petty but you need to say it and he kind
of did the other day and a grudging sort
of all the off hearty sort of like my
son agreeing to take out the garbage um
you know what the hell is going on in
president Trump's mind because it seems
to be different than what's going on in
the minds of his top advisors he seems
to be vastly more reluctant to be
critical of Russia on any loved to do
any of this than anybody around him hi
it's concerning all right on this
cheerful note we'll go to questions
please we have microphones that that
will come please identify yourself and
please ask a question and not make a
statement right here
he's coming you just can't see him herb
Rose I'm going to parse your words just
a little bit you said that you have a
bill that you want to bring forward
about concerning actions we should be
taking with respect to Russia I wonder
if you could be a little bit more
specific about what might be in that
bill and also what the chances of
success might be after you just
mentioned it the attitude of the
President and perhaps a lot of his
supporters in the Republican side how
much of a chance do you think you have
for success in heading in that direction
and also what hasn't been mentioned here
before I agree with you the actions that
you're recommending be taken in Ukraine
and also with respect to the internet
and pushing forward against Russia but
what about increasing sanctions because
I'm betting once you get into the what
was discussed by a lot of people prior
to the election and immediately after
election Flynn and some of the other
people sanctions were being discussed
there I would speculate I don't know but
I think that's what Russia is most
concerned with today the sanctions taken
against it or at least what Putin is
most concerned with well two things
first of all the earth there is great
bipartisan support in Congress for a
comprehensive strategy to counter
Russian aggression so the house seems to
be a little bit more reluctant to go in
this direction than the Senate McCain
and Graham and others are tremendous
leaders over there the house has been
more muted to put it mildly on this
issue so I'm worried about how we get
there in the house but I think there is
bipartisan support for this as I've said
there's support within the Trump
administration amongst the top level
people for
and you're not here as far as what my
bill does the most important thing it
does is it calls for the administration
to put together a strategy and then it
has seven or eight different points and
it would really tax my memory to
remember all of them as to what what
what pieces of that one of is increased
president in Eastern Europe to deter
what Russia is doing another piece is
figure out what's going on in the cyber
world and aggressively counter it
another piece is the messaging to really
understand the broad effort that Russia
is making to plant new stories in
advance a narrative there's like seven
or eight different suggestions as to
what that strategy should look like and
what some of the key components of it
sorry I left out the one that's most
important to me we strengthen our
alliances you know we strengthen NATO we
strengthen the EU basically build up
supporters from the notion that we need
to counter this Russian aggression and
there are people who want to do that so
I do think it has a decent chance of of
getting broader support because there is
bipartisan support for this for this
concern the president's not helpful but
hopefully we can sort of move that
around to a different more positive
direction I think don't miss one element
of your question I think that was saying
oh sanctions that's right you know it's
interesting I'm happy to push sanctions
and all of that but then I'm cautious
about is the more desperate Russia
becomes the more you put them into a
position where nationalism is the only
card they have left to play so part of
what is going undermine Putin is for the
people in Russia to get more focused on
domestic economic opportunity and less
focused on Russian greatness now and I'd
be curious to get sort of the feedback
here because there's an inherent
contradiction what I just said that I
personally can't resolve off the top of
my head because on the one hand we want
to make it clear to the Russian people
that Putin is a failure that he is not
providing for them he is not taking care
of them on the other hand to the extent
it gets pushed too far it's like you
know you want the dog calm down you
don't want him backed into a corner back
into a corner where there's no economic
opportunity and if Putin can
laying the rest of the world for doing
that to them instead of owning it does
that make it more difficult for us to
get them away from looking at
nationalism and greater Russia and all
of that and I don't I don't have the
sort of granular understanding that my
colleague here has of you know Russian
society to know you know sort of where
the Russian people would come down on
that but starving Russia
strikes me as a double edged sword would
be the better way to sum up what I said
excellent got the question right here
Matthew Maria was a senior official in
the Obama administration responsible for
determining the timing and scope of
sanctions against Russia at the Commerce
Department my question is I want to
stick with this very difficult issue
which you've articulated very well which
is in a world in which the President
Putin has made it clear that he does not
believe in a non zero sum game that he
doesn't have a way of thinking about a
world in which the United States and
Russia can win simultaneously and in a
world in which we're headed towards more
sanctions towards Russia and maybe
sanction doubt in a way in the sense
that if we go too far with sanctions
will will deprive ourselves of options
to induce better behavior domestically
in Russia and this this is your point
that where where are the incentives for
growing economically a new middle class
in Russia and what role can the United
States play in that if we are indeed
imposing more sanctions are you are you
concerned about that and have you
thought that there are ways around that
or through that particular dilemma yes I
have and personally as I said I think
ramping up I think we do have to
sanction them and I think when you're
talking about there's a lotta different
ways to sanction them you know kicking
out a bunch of their officials who we
know are spies that's
and and others blocking travel for
prudence people that we know are up to
no good
I think is a more appropriate way to do
it than to place economic sanctions on
Russia that are likely to hurt the
Russian people and I think we need to
rethink that I don't think that economic
sanctions trying to drive Russia to
their knees I think Putin Putin will do
that just fine on his own
because he has no economic plan
whatsoever for helping the Russian
people and I think we need to I think
I'd much prefer us to spend the time
like I said on an information campaign
to try to reach the Russian people or
let them know what what Putin is truly
doing to them so I have that concern
right there
Thank You Alice I'll see with Talking
Points Memo I wanted to ask if the
congressman could respond to the
Bloomberg report on Russian hacking
efforts targeting state election systems
many more states than were previously
known as many as 39 does that fit with
briefings you've received yeah and it's
really rather concerning us I know the
conclusion has been reached that Russia
was unable actually to alter what
happened in our voting machines but how
would you know and this was something
that was a big issue remember
congressman rush Holt made this a
signature piece of his when you have
these machines where it is done by
computer and there's no paper ballot and
there's no paper receipt a recount
doesn't matter because you're simply
recounting what the computer said you
don't know how people actually voted I
think the security of our voting system
is enormous Lee important and I think we
need to go I am there ought to you ought
to require paper receipts in addition to
what goes on within the computer to know
because you don't know what happened and
sorry this is kind of off topic but the
Republicans have many talking points
that drive me crazy but one of the ones
that is right at the top of the list is
the you can't prove that Russian
interference changed a single vote I
also can't prove that the moon's made of
cheese what the hell's that got to do
with anything
yeah of course you can't you Nicki you
can't prove that a given ad changed it
he said nothing to do with nothing all
right
Russia tried to alter our election and
ultimately they got the result that they
wanted what made a given voter decide
this is a subconscious thing that I've
long understood on a good level that the
people people subconsciously vote as
much as they consciously vote for
certain things so we need to get away
from this idea that if you can't prove
that Russia's activity changed a single
vote then really it's not a big deal
right no it's an enormous deal because
what they're doing is undermining our
democracy and if they could go into
those they could hack into there
computer systems and change the votes in
certain places they would absolutely do
it there's no question about it and how
can we prove whether they did or didn't
I don't know again I'm out of my depth
in terms of understanding what you can
forensic ly get out of a computer system
but the security of our electoral system
state by state is something that I think
we need to pay a great deal more
attention to all right please right here
yes then there's a guy on the other side
of the room here has been desperate to
get in oh you're looking this way I'm
looking that way okay he's looking at me
all right so let's do that you know go
ahead and that you yeah and then we go
to you next go ahead I'm John zebra with
the DoD just two quick questions first
sir why do you think the threat seems to
be misunderstood or kind of downplayed
it seems like we've been doing this for
three years and you still here hey we
should let Russia have the Crimean then
we can work with them on Syria I've
heard that kind of those kind of ideas
out there and then how would you counter
some of the anti Alliance ideas that are
going around that these Alliance just
kind of suck American resources and they
don't really help us because one of your
original points was we need to
strengthen our alliances thank you on
the second point first I don't think
people have a sufficient appreciation
for the degree to which our country has
benefited from the post-world War two
environment and again this is an aspect
of President Trump's message that I find
completely appalling as he describes
this sort of burnt-out hellscape that
America apparently was until January
21st it it bears no resemblance to
reality now understand something I you
know I grew up in a blue-collar family
and my father was remember a machinist
Union and a baggage handler for an
airline and I understand that
blue-collar workers are struggling in
this country I I do very profoundly that
job my father had 1985 paid 16 dollars
an hour with full benefits in 2015 it
paid 937 an hour with no benefits which
is why the elementary school that I went
to now has 95% free and reduced lunch so
there are issues
in terms of how we make a broader base
to our economic prosperity but no
society in the history of the world has
lived better top to bottom economically
then we have post-world War two and a
lot of that is because of the economic
growth and stability that was brought
about because of all of the alliances
that we built the alliances would not
with just with Europe but with Southeast
Asia with Latin America and I think we
don't have an appreciation for the
prosperity that it brought us and we
have to make it clear that that can go
away a world where we are isolated
engaged in trade wars leads to greater
nationalism I mean you can simply go
back to the turn of the twentieth
century
when everyone assumed that that wave of
globalization meant that we would never
again fight that you know we were so
interconnected that it would never
happen and as we were treated away from
that we wound up with two bloody world
wars so number one the most important
thing is to make it clear that we
benefit from this global order in a way
that the rest the rest of the world does
to some degree but not to the same
degree that we do as far as downplaying
the Russian threat line I think it's
because we don't understand it and again
like I said I'll cop to the fact that it
was less of us probably a year and a
half ago I didn't know what Russia was
up to I mean we were very focused on
Isis on al Qaeda and with good reason
and you know it took a real education I
didn't know all the stuff that they were
doing so I think most people are unaware
of the comprehensive nature of Russia's
efforts to undermine us and so we have
to make that case which is why I thank a
for giving us this forum today to do
that do we have time for one more guest
absol yes the long-suffering questioner
right if I cut it off at that pit will
it real bad so yes I think thank you
very much representative my name is
Dalton Booker I'm with the Osgood Centre
for International Studies and my
question is considering recent recent
events in Iran with the
liner suffering a minor defeat in the
reelection of their president and his
signaling that he is more willing to
work with the West you think there's any
chance to to use an antiquated term try
and draw them out of Russia's sphere of
influence into ours or do you think that
ship has sailed long ago I think there's
a real chance there and I think this is
a misunderstanding
missed opportunity and politics so one
things again that I worry about and I'll
be interested to see how how the
president squares this particular circle
because as I said he has you know shown
an affinity for Russia and an
unwillingness to criticize them that is
truly remarkable but at the same time
he's very much all about how bad Iran is
and Russia and Iran are like buddies so
how does how does that work in his mind
I don't have any idea
so I hurry how that played out but look
we should not be choosing sides in the
sunni-shia Civil War we should not be
saying we're all-in with the Sunnis
there is an enormous opportunity in Iraq
the overwhelming majority of Iranian
people want greater freedom greater
democracy they like the West in the
United States now yes the hardliners who
run the country are in a different place
and is a patient long game to move in a
different direction but if we dive in
inside 100 percent with Saudi Arabia and
UAE and everything else and say let's go
to war with the Shia then I think we
will create greater instability in the
Middle East and a longer term conflict
and if we try to some degree to broker a
better understanding between those two
and let us not forget for all of the you
know concerns that we have but Iran and
they are legitimate Iran's support for
different groups the Isis al Qaeda that
arose out of a radical extremist Sunni
ideology the Salafists to some degree
but also and this is Saudi Arabia the
Wahhabi ISM
I never quite say that word right but
you know what I'm saying
that is the Saudi Arabian interpretation
of the religion now Saudi Arabia is
trying to reform I think their new king
wants to move in a more positive
direction but women still aren't driving
there and that is still the extreme
version of the religion that the
dominates and we've got to get them to
the point where they're not ok with it
up to the point where it turns violent
against the kingdom that they understand
that preaching that type of extremist
ideology naturally leads to the violence
that comes and to try and roll it back
now I will send that with a foreign
minister and a number of occasions I get
the feeling that they are trying to move
in a different and more more positive
direction and I will also agree that you
cannot move too far too fast or the
hardliners will turn on you but the
ultimate you know solution to a more
peaceful Middle East is for some sort of
calming of the tensions between Iran and
the rest of the Middle East not a
ratcheting them up and thinking we
should fight an all-out war over it so
that's the other thing that's sort of
troubling about the whole Qatar
situation because and there's other
things going on there that haven't been
widely reported but part of it is guitar
has tried to find ways to get along with
Iran and I think that is one of the
reasons why Saudi Arabia and some of the
other countries have turned on them as
aggressively as they have and we should
be trying to broker a better consensus
on that instead of just saying that
Iran's bad and we're all-in with the
Gulf Arab states to take on the Persians
I don't think that's in our best
interest I think we need to play a
little bit more of a calculated game
there than just you know black or white
we're on this side let's go
representative Smith I know you have to
run thank you so much for coming I think
it will do it again
yeah nice we enjoyed the terrific
audience